[Music]
last week cher sent out a tweet that got
some attention take a look she said this
is real she said if Romney gets elected
I don't know if I can breathe the same
air as him and his right-wing racist
homophobic women hating teabagger
masters well in the event that Romney
does get elected it could happen I just
wanted to offer share a place to live
where she won't have to breathe the same
air we've built this for it's the share
[Applause]
complete with a year's supply of air and
rice a roni per share
and at Pace now ladies and gentlemen if
you didn't for any reason laugh at the
share biodome joke it's probably for two
reasons one it's not that funny and two
if you're a younger viewer you have no
idea who share is don't worry this is a
common problem for comedy shows like
this one and for you and the millions of
viewers who don't get some of the
celebrity references used in our jokes
help is on the way
take a look hello I'm Corbin Bernsen one
of the stars of the TV show psych but
you might also remember me as attorney
Arnie Becker from the popular 80's legal
drama la longue of course many of you
are too young to remember la la that's
why I'm here to tell you about the
Museum of old pop-culture references our
mission help younger viewers like you
understand the dated pop-culture
references made by comedy writers in
their 30s and 40s it's all here
political punchlines one-hit wonders
notable skanks Lange products you'll
find out who they are and why out of
touch comedy writers refuse to let them
go don't know who Ruben Studdard is you
will after visiting fatties of
yesteryear a lot to look back at
celebrities mock for their struggles
with weight thanks a museum the whole
pop culture references now I know that
Louie Anderson is fat Hugh Grant likes
prostitutes and John Wayne Bobbitt had
his dong sliced off I used to think
Madonna was just an old lady but I found
out she was also a singer a terrible
actress a pornographer and Dennis
Rodman's old girlfriend and I also found
out who done his Rodman is
and if you visited before come back
because our museum is constantly being
updated with almost current pop culture
references so spend some time and
discover what your uncle find so funny
after all you wouldn't want to be left
out in the cold like John Wayne Bobbitt
speen Asst ok I get that now it's still
hilarious Museum of old pop culture
references located between Central Perk
and mystic pizza in the Twin Peaks
shopping plaza for more information call
five six seven five three
[Applause]